And now I'm here in Lambda World, and holy, I love this conference. Like, when I speak to him, I feel like I see Jesus. And the other one is, I seem to like functional programming. So we see each other every sunset, we walk up to a mountain nearby where we live, and we talk functional programming. And it's elegant, it's beautiful when you write it that way. Why would anyone want to program any other way welcome to ads be the podcast episode 204 recorded on october 4th 2024 my name is connor and today we record live from lambda world 2024
现在我身处 Lambda World 大会，天哪，我太喜欢这个会议了。就像我跟他说的那样，见到他感觉就像见到了耶稣。另一件事是，我似乎喜欢上了函数式编程。所以我们每个日落时分都会见面，走到我们住处附近的一座山上，谈论函数式编程。那种写法既优雅又美妙。为什么还会有人想用其他方式编程呢？欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 204 期，录制于 2024 年 10 月 4 日。我是 Connor，今天我们是在 Lambda World 2024 大会现场进行直播录制。
i interview three different individuals, Andor Paynesesh, Stephen Taylor, and an attendee from the conference. All right, we are here. Post Lambda World, it is 2024. Technically, is it post? We're headed to the, I think it's after party? After party, yes. After party. And we are here with previous guests. I have no idea what the episode was. Probably 202 minus roughly 50 plus. It's like 70. So probably 140. 2023, right? But it was in May and now it's October. So we're here with Anders Painsish, who was a previous guest when we were at Lambda Days 2023. Not to be confused with Lambda World Cadiz, we are here in Spain. Previously, we were here with Anders, who was a speaker back at Lambda Days in Krakow,
我采访了三位不同的人：Andor Paynesesh、Stephen Taylor 以及一位参会者。好了，我们到了。Lambda World 之后，现在是 2024 年。严格来说，是之后吗？我们正前往，我想是会后派对？会后派对，没错。会后派对。我们现在和之前的嘉宾在一起。我完全不记得是哪一期了。大概是 202 减去 50 多吧。大概是 70 期左右。所以可能是 140 期。2023 年，对吧？但那是五月，现在是十月。所以我们和 Anders Painsish 在一起，他曾是我们 2023 年在克拉科夫参加 Lambda Days 时的嘉宾。别和 Lambda World Cadiz 搞混了，我们现在是在西班牙。之前，我们和 Anders 在克拉科夫的 Lambda Days 上见过面，他当时是演讲嘉宾。
Poland. You were not speaking at Lambda World. You did just speak at Lambda Days 2024. Yes. So tell us first, how has this conference been? What was your favorite talk? And then maybe also tell us what were you speaking about at Lambda Days, which I did not attend this year, but you did. So let me just recap.
波兰。你这次没有在 Lambda World 上演讲。你确实刚在 Lambda Days 2024 上做过演讲。是的。那么首先告诉我们，这次会议感觉如何？你最喜欢的演讲是什么？然后也许还可以告诉我们你在 Lambda Days 上讲了什么，我今年没去，但你去了。所以让我先回顾一下。
I can't really remember all the talks. Basically, I came for like as a part of vacation, a very long vacation, and I'm ending my vacation here. And this was a nice two-day conference, first with the workshop with you, like the array programming. And when I looked at just the program here, I was like, okay, no, I don't want to do functional programming in this conference. There were so many nice array programming talks.
我记不清所有的演讲了。基本上，我来这里是度假的一部分，一个很长的假期，而我在这里结束我的假期。这是一个很棒的两天会议，首先是和你一起参加的研讨会，关于数组编程。当我看到这里的日程表时，我就想，好吧，我不打算在这个会议上做函数式编程。这里有太多精彩的数组编程演讲了。
I just went there. I went in. And basically, that's it. What was your favorite talk? Interestingly. But I found the most interesting one is from Jana. Oh, yes. From the music.
我就直接去了。我进去了。基本上就是这样。你最喜欢的演讲是什么？有趣的是。但我发现最有趣的是 Jana 的那场。哦，是的。关于音乐的。
Yeah. And I think you need to tell the story for Jana's talk. Well, it was, I mean, there was actually two different music talks. There was the opening keynote by Chris Ford of ThoughtWorks, I believe. And he gave a talk called The Butcher Bird Combinator and did some live music playing. And he was doing his coding in Clojure. A great talk, less pedagogical and more kind of searching through hobbies and trying to teach something along the way.
是的，我觉得你需要讲讲 Jana 那场演讲的故事。嗯，其实有两场不同的音乐演讲。一场是开幕主题演讲，由 ThoughtWorks 的 Chris Ford 带来，我想应该是他。他做了一个名为“屠夫鸟组合子”（The Butcher Bird Combinator）的演讲，并进行了一些现场音乐演奏。他用 Clojure 语言进行编码。那是一场很棒的演讲，与其说是教学，不如说是在爱好中探索，并试图在过程中传授一些东西。
Whereas, I'm not sure, is it Johanna or Johanna? Do you know the pronunciation? I don't remember. I don't remember. We'll say Johanna, but if we're pronouncing your name incorrectly, we apologize. Odersky, which I discovered today, does make her the daughter of Martin Odersky, famously the creator of the Scala language. And she was doing sort of music exploration similar to what Chris Ford was doing, but she was doing it in the Scala language.
至于，我不确定是 Johanna 还是 Johanna？你知道怎么发音吗？我不记得了。我不记得了。我们就叫她 Johanna 吧，如果发音不对，我们道歉。Odersky，我今天才发现，这让她成为了 Martin Odersky 的女儿，也就是著名的 Scala 语言创始人。她做的是类似于 Chris Ford 所做的音乐探索，但她是用 Scala 语言完成的。
We're about to enter this music bar, and it's probably going to ruin, absolutely destroy the ability to do interviews. We might need to pull people out here. We'll see. So that was your favorite talk. You also started your vacation off two weeks ago at a Unity conference, correct? At a Unity conference, exactly. In Barcelona. In Barcelona.
我们马上要进这家音乐酒吧了，这可能会毁掉，彻底破坏采访的能力。我们可能需要把人拉出来。我们走着瞧。所以那是你最喜欢的演讲。你两周前还在 Unity 大会上开始了你的假期，对吧？在 Unity 大会上，没错。在巴塞罗那。在巴塞罗那。
Do you want to mention anything or any highlights? How did that compare to Lambda World? I'm guessing a very different conference. It's a very different conference. It's an industrial conference. But I really wanted to see how the game development is nowadays. And I'm just looking into it to just make my own little games using Unity. So I found, yeah, let's start my vacation with the Unity Night Conference in Barcelona.
你想提一下什么亮点吗？那和 Lambda World 相比如何？我猜是一个非常不同的会议。这是一个非常不同的会议。这是一个工业会议。但我真的很想看看现在的游戏开发是什么样子的。我正在研究它，想用 Unity 制作我自己的小游戏。所以我发现，好吧，让我在巴塞罗那的 Unity Night 大会上开始我的假期。
Stay in Spain for two weeks and finish here in Cadiz and after I go home. That's how you got to do your vacations, folks. You got to start at a conference, then take two weeks off, then end at a conference. That's the way to do it. Last but not least, tell us about your talk that you gave at Lambda Days 2024. Is it online already? Can people watch it? And what was it about?
在西班牙待两周，然后在加的斯结束，之后我就回家了。伙计们，这就是你们度假的方式。你得从一个会议开始，然后休假两周，最后在另一个会议结束。这才是正确的方法。最后但同样重要的是，告诉我们你在 Lambda Days 2024 上做的演讲。它上线了吗？人们能看吗？它是关于什么的？
I hope it's online. I haven't watched it. So I just gave a talk about let's grab your seats but basically what we are doing as a research with the University of Nottingham is what is called dependently typed Python. Whoa! Dependently typed Python? Yeah, because our message
我希望它上线了。我还没看过。我刚做了一个关于——让我们坐好——但基本上我们正在与诺丁汉大学进行的研究，被称为“依赖类型 Python”。哇！依赖类型 Python？是的，因为我们的信息
here that dependently typed things could be as a nice software engineering thing, as a nice story, nice tool but we can't really popularize dependent types within FP context because FP is very limited audience. So we are giving this try to implement a type system for Python or a subset of Python, which is actually uses dependent types. Is this something that is usable now or is it still in the research sort of development phase?
在这里，依赖类型的东西可以作为一个很好的软件工程事物，作为一个很好的故事，很好的工具，但我们无法在函数式编程（FP）环境中推广依赖类型，因为 FP 的受众非常有限。所以我们正在尝试为 Python 或 Python 的一个子集实现一个类型系统，它实际上使用了依赖类型。这是现在可以使用的东西，还是仍处于研究开发阶段？
It's still in very alpha, very useless in that sense, very researchy. We are just gathering ideas, discussing things. Okay, well, that does sound super exciting. We'll put a link in the show. I'm not sure if anything is on GitHub yet, but... The code is open source in GitHub, but it's like
它仍处于非常早期的 alpha 阶段，在这个意义上非常没用，非常学术。我们只是在收集想法，讨论事情。好吧，这听起来确实超级令人兴奋。我们会在节目中放一个链接。我不确定 GitHub 上是否有东西，但是……代码在 GitHub 上是开源的，但它就像
it's not serious at all because we are like interpreter one, interpreter two, interpreter three, serious, interpreter one, interpreter two, so it's more like this prototyping, experimenting, but if you are interested in this topic, just reach me out and we can involve more people
一点也不严肃，因为我们就像解释器 1，解释器 2，解释器 3，严肃点，解释器 1，解释器 2，所以它更像是这种原型设计，实验，但如果你对这个话题感兴趣，请联系我，我们可以让更多人参与进来
in the long run. Awesome. I'll make sure to include your contact info. We did that the same time last year. We're almost getting hit by mopeds and motorcycles because we're standing in the middle of the road outside this music bar. But we'll be sure to include a link to the GitHub repo if folks maybe want to get involved or something. There's Steven. He's walking in. We'll talk to him later.
从长远来看。太棒了。我一定会附上你的联系方式。我们去年同一时间也做了同样的事。我们差点被轻便摩托车和摩托车撞到，因为我们站在音乐酒吧外面的马路中间。但我们一定会附上 GitHub 仓库的链接，如果大家想参与的话。那是 Steven。他走过来了。我们稍后再和他谈。
Probably not in the bar because it sounds very loud in there. Thanks so much for being interviewed again. Are you have any conference plans on your schedule yet? Because it seems like a year and a half, a year apart, we seem to run into each other at these functional conferences. Well, I hope that we will run into each other, but
可能不在酒吧里，因为里面声音太大了。非常感谢你再次接受采访。你的日程表上有任何会议计划吗？因为看起来每隔一年半，我们似乎总能在这些函数式会议上相遇。嗯，我希望我们能相遇，但是
I have no plans. I usually just make these things up and when I see a conference, this is interesting, buy the ticket, done. Alright, well, I guarantee you we'll see each other again. The question is when. I guess the listener will just have to wait and see when that happens next. Thanks so much. Thank you very much.
我没有任何计划。我通常只是临时起意，当我看到一个会议，觉得这很有趣，买票，搞定。好吧，我保证我们还会再见面的。问题是什么时候。我想听众只能等着看什么时候发生了。非常感谢。非常感谢。
Awesome. All right. We are back. And we're here with... Correct? Yes, correct. And we were just inside. Honestly, this is going to be a pretty bumpy podcast, folks.
太棒了。好了。我们回来了。我们和……在一起，对吧？是的，没错。我们刚才在里面。老实说，这会是一个相当颠簸的播客，伙计们。
We just finished talking to Anders. And then we went into the music bar every time we talked to someone we're gonna have to come out here because it's way too noisy inside and just walked by he saw me he said hey are you connor and you said i heard you on co-recursive which was from years ago and you mentioned that you started programming apl so maybe tell us about your apl journey and then we can talk about lambda World. Yeah, it's a bit difficult because it was many years ago. I don't know, you had a very persuasive way to share on why APL is good,
我们刚和 Anders 谈完。然后我们进了音乐酒吧，每次我们和别人谈话都得出来，因为里面太吵了。他刚才走过，他看到我，他说嘿，你是 Connor 吗？你说我听过你在 Co-recursive 上的节目，那是几年前的事了，你提到你开始学习 APL，所以也许告诉我们你的 APL 之旅，然后我们可以谈谈 Lambda World。是的，这有点困难，因为那是很多年前的事了。我不知道，你有一种非常有说服力的方式来分享为什么 APL 很好，
like the benefit of being able to put down your thoughts in a very short manner and be quick about it. Yeah, absolutely. It's like, I like to say it's coding at the speed of thought. You know, you try and program the way you program in APL, in Java or C++, it's coding at the speed of thought. You know, you try and program the way you program in APL, in Java or C++. It's just impossible. Yeah, and he also shared some good thoughts about general competitive programming.
比如能够以非常简短的方式写下你的想法并快速完成的好处。是的，绝对。就像我喜欢说的，这是“以思维的速度编码”。你知道，你尝试用 Java 或 C++ 以你在 APL 中的方式编程，这是不可能的。是的，他还分享了一些关于一般竞技编程的好想法。
It all persuaded me to start following you to the point where I started listening to you more than I did to call recursive. And eventually, like, I just went into that rabbit hole and got into the APL community. You said, I think, you ended up meeting Adam online. Yes, I ended up meeting them online. They have a very weird chat forum. I don't remember if it's Yahoo who drives this chat forum. Maybe it has changed.
这一切都说服了我开始关注你，以至于我开始听你的节目比听 Co-recursive 还要多。最终，我就掉进了那个兔子洞，进入了 APL 社区。你说，我想，你最终是在网上遇到了 Adam。是的，我最终在网上遇到了他们。他们有一个非常奇怪的聊天论坛。我不记得是不是雅虎驱动了这个聊天论坛。也许它已经变了。
I think, I know now, these days, it's the APL Stack Exchange. So I'm not sure if that was the same one you ran into. Yeah, it's a very weird old website. You needed to register with a weird account to get accepted by an admin. But I was active there for a while, and Adam was very nice to me. He's very strong in driving that community.
我想，我知道现在，这些天，它是 APL Stack Exchange。所以我不知道那是不是你遇到的同一个。是的，这是一个非常奇怪的老网站。你需要用一个奇怪的账户注册才能被管理员接受。但我活跃了一段时间，Adam 对我非常好。他在推动那个社区方面非常强大。
And I don't know, somehow along the way, I started hanging out there every week. I don't know, he sort of way, I started hanging out there every week. I don't know, he sort of got me into a job interview once. Oh, really? Yeah, that sort of got the ball rolling with interviews and everything, so I started doing more job interviews, and all of a sudden I'm working as a software engineer, so life changed, and it all started with you.
我不知道，不知何故，我开始每周都在那里闲逛。我不知道，他以某种方式让我参加了一次工作面试。哦，真的吗？是的，那让面试和一切事情都顺利进行了，所以我开始做更多的面试，突然间我成了一名软件工程师，所以生活改变了，而这一切都始于你。
Wow, I'm not sure if maybe it was a small role, but it sounds like Adam played an even larger role, and I know he listens to this podcast. So I'm sure, let's see, I mentioned on the last time we were interviewing Anders is that we're constantly almost getting hit by these mopeds and motorcycles. But yes, Adam will be, I'm sure, thrilled to hear that his, whatever role he played, it led to you getting a job in software development. So you've been here at Lambda World.
哇，我不确定这是否是一个小角色，但听起来 Adam 发挥了更大的作用，我知道他听这个播客。所以我肯定，让我们看看，我在上次采访 Anders 时提到，我们差点被这些轻便摩托车和摩托车撞到。但是的，Adam 一定会很高兴听到他所扮演的任何角色都让你找到了一份软件开发的工作。所以你一直在这里参加 Lambda World。
How have you found, is this your first time? How have you found it? It's my first time. The reason I started with this functional thing is because I got a colleague who started last year, and he transformed my life as well. Like, when I speak to him, I feel like I see Jesus.
你觉得怎么样，这是你第一次来吗？你觉得它怎么样？这是我第一次。我开始接触函数式编程的原因是因为我有一个去年入职的同事，他也改变了我的生活。就像我跟他说的那样，见到他感觉就像见到了耶稣。
And he's very persuasive in this. Like, I think I've been in two conversions in my programming career. One was when I realized it's better to cooperate with people. And the other one is I seem to like functional programming.
他在这一点上非常有说服力。我想我在我的编程生涯中经历过两次转变。一次是我意识到与人合作更好。另一次是我似乎喜欢上了函数式编程。
And during the past year, I've been reading books about it, and now I'm here in Lambda World, and holy, I love this conference. The coworker that you worked with, was he an evangelist or she an evangelist for a specific language? Or was it just functional programming in general? I think just functional language in general.
在过去的一年里，我一直在读关于它的书，现在我来到了 Lambda World，天哪，我太喜欢这个会议了。和你一起工作的那个同事，他是某种特定语言的传道者吗？还是仅仅是函数式编程？我想只是函数式语言。
I think his background is actually mathematics. Okay. But he's in love with category theory. And he's feeding me every day. Like, we're neighbors now. So we see each other every sunset. We walk up to a mountain nearby where we live, and we talk functional programming.
我想他的背景其实是数学。好的。但他热爱范畴论。他每天都在喂养我。就像，我们现在是邻居了。所以我们每个日落时分都会见面。我们走到我们住处附近的一座山上，谈论函数式编程。
Oh, you mentioned that you're based out of Sweden, correct? Yeah. In Gothenburg, there's a mountain in the middle of the town, so we hang out over there. It's easy to catch us, because we're two guys talking functional programming. So you've enjoyed the conference. Any highlights or favorite talks?
哦，你提到你住在瑞典，对吧？是的。在哥德堡，城中心有一座山，所以我们就在那里闲逛。很容易找到我们，因为我们是两个谈论函数式编程的家伙。所以你很享受这次会议。有什么亮点或最喜欢的演讲吗？
Okay, so I go to two conferences a year which is I think a lot in this conference I was also attending workshops and I felt like I realized I think I learned better through interaction so this workshop gave me new tools to play with when I'm going back on Sunday I'm going to do play some with some new toys but really the people I was hanging out with after the conference, like when we were having dinner, I got even more wisdom. So now I have like three more subjects to read on. One was Y Combinator. One was Category Theory for Programmers, which is a lecture course sort of thing.
好吧，我一年参加两次会议，我觉得这已经很多了。在这个会议上，我也参加了研讨会，我意识到我通过互动学得更好。所以这个研讨会给了我新的工具，当我周日回去时，我会玩一些新玩具。但真正让我受益匪浅的是会议结束后和我一起闲逛的人，比如我们吃晚饭的时候，我得到了更多的智慧。所以现在我有三个主题要读。一个是 Y 组合子。一个是《程序员的范畴论》，那是一种讲座课程。
Both lectures and a textbook, yeah, by Bartosz Maluski, yeah. Yeah, and then there was the third one. I think it was something about equality of objects, something in category theory. I don't remember the exact title, but I took screenshots of everything, and I have more things to read on. I mean, people that listen to podcasts are probably sick of hearing it, but the best part of conferences,
既有讲座也有教科书，是的，由 Bartosz Maluski 编写。是的，然后是第三个。我想是关于对象相等性的东西，范畴论里的。我不记得确切的标题了，但我给所有东西截了图，我有更多东西要读。我的意思是，听播客的人可能已经听腻了，但会议最好的部分，
I mean, the talks are great, but the best part is the lunches, the hallway track, the going out to a music bar afterwards, bumping into folks, and then, yeah,
我的意思是，演讲很棒，但最好的部分是午餐，走廊交流，之后去音乐酒吧，撞见朋友，然后，是的，
just sharing. Everyone here is, I don't want to say a super nerd, but we're all interested in adjacent things, and it's just, it's like, you know,
只是分享。这里的每个人，我不想说是一个超级书呆子，但我们都对相邻的事物感兴趣，这就像，你知道，
a theme park or whatever. You know, some people like to play video games and whatnot, but, like, the folks here, we all nerd out on our own nerd stuff, and it's just like a theme park or whatever. Some people like to play video games and whatnot but the folks here, we all nerd out on our own nerd stuff and it's just cool to be hanging out and chatting with folks. Yeah, I agree. I think that these people were very
一个主题公园什么的。你知道，有些人喜欢玩电子游戏什么的，但是，这里的人，我们都在自己的书呆子领域里钻研，这就像一个主题公园什么的。有些人喜欢玩电子游戏什么的，但这里的人，我们都在自己的书呆子领域里钻研，和大家一起闲逛聊天真的很酷。是的，我同意。我认为这些人非常
enthusiastic and shown a lot of passion for functional programming. But really I'm very happy to see you because when I saw you on the day I was like, oh I've followed you for years and now I have a chance. It seemed like it would never happen. You're just a guy from the internet, but it turns out you're real. It turns out I'm a real person, folks.
热情，对函数式编程表现出了极大的热情。但真的，我很高兴见到你，因为那天我看到你时，我就想，哦，我关注你很多年了，现在我有机会了。这看起来永远不会发生。你只是互联网上的一个人，但事实证明你是真实的。事实证明我是一个真实的人，伙计们。
My parents will love to hear that. But no, awesome bumping into you. If folks haven't been to Lambda World or Lambda Days, you said two conferences. What's the other conference you go to? Earlier this year, I went to Dev World. The year before, it was Gala Days Earlier this year, I went to DevWorld. The year before was Scala Days, and then I've been to QCon.
我父母会很高兴听到这个。但没关系，撞见你太棒了。如果大家还没去过 Lambda World 或 Lambda Days，你说过两个会议。你还去哪个会议？今年早些时候，我去了 Dev World。前一年是 Scala Days，然后我去过 QCon。
I just go to two times a year because that's what my job allows me. And if you had to recommend, is LambdaWorld and Cadiz at the top of the list, or is it any conference really? Right now, it's this one. Easy. But it's also a personal
我一年只去两次，因为我的工作只允许我这样。如果你必须推荐，Lambda World 和加的斯是首选吗，还是任何会议都可以？现在，是这一个。毫无疑问。但这也是我个人的
hobby of mine. This one strikes home to me. I mean, if you're into functional programming, the functional conferences are going to obviously hit harder than the other ones, for sure. Yeah, it feels like a religion to me right now. It's a bit unhealthy, but I love it. I'm very happy about this. That is awesome, man. Thank you so much for agreeing in the midst of socializing to come out here. I can think of Adam, at least, to say hi to him. I'm very thankful for him. And I'm thankful for you. Thank you for existing.
爱好。这一个让我有宾至如归的感觉。我的意思是，如果你喜欢函数式编程，函数式会议显然比其他的更吸引人，这是肯定的。是的，它现在对我来说感觉像一种宗教。这有点不健康，但我喜欢它。我对此非常高兴。这太棒了，伙计。非常感谢你在社交中抽出时间出来。我至少可以想到 Adam，向他问好。我很感谢他。我也很感谢你。谢谢你的存在。
Really, you just made a random podcast episode and all of a sudden it's tracked in my life. Everyone has that person, though, right? For me, I mean, there's a bunch of folks, but you know, the one I just finished interviewing him on the last episode was a guy named Sean Parent. He gave a talk that I ended up seeing in like 2017 or 18. And that totally changed like the trajectory of like my interests in my career. So, I mean, it's awesome to hear
真的，你只是做了一个随机的播客剧集，突然间它就追踪到了我的生活。每个人都有那样的人，对吧？对我来说，我的意思是，有一群人，但你知道，我在上一期采访的那个人叫 Sean Parent。他做了一个演讲，我最终在 2017 或 18 年左右看到了。这完全改变了我职业生涯中兴趣的轨迹。所以，我的意思是，听到
that I did the same for you, but everyone has that person right at some point. So, yeah, I think you're right. Thanks so much, man. Enjoy the rest of the night. And yeah, we'll see you back in there yeah you too have a good one we are here once again it's still lambda world 2024 and we're here with a first time adsp guest but a long time panelist of the array cast steven taylor who is not just a panelist of Arraycast, he was the presenter of what was my favorite talk of Lambda World.
我为你做了同样的事情太棒了，但每个人在某个时候都有那样的人，对吧？所以，是的，我想你是对的。非常感谢，伙计。享受剩下的夜晚吧。是的，我们会在里面再见。是的，你也是，祝你过得愉快。我们再次来到这里，现在仍然是 Lambda World 2024，我们和一位第一次参加 ADSP 的嘉宾在一起，但他是一位长期的 Arraycast 小组成员，Steven Taylor，他不仅是 Arraycast 的小组成员，他还是我最喜欢的 Lambda World 演讲的演讲者。
I'm probably a bit biased based on the topic you were talking about, but we're going to throw it over to you. Maybe you can tell us a bit about your talk and about your Lambda World 2024 experience. Thank you, Connor. It's great to be on ADS-B. Well, it was very interesting to get the invitation to talk at a functional programming conference. I've long leaned towards functional style. This prompted me to dig into the roots of functional programming and its connection with APL,
我可能对你谈论的话题有点偏见，但我们要把它交给你。也许你可以告诉我们一点关于你的演讲和你的 Lambda World 2024 体验。谢谢你，Connor。很高兴来到 ADSP。嗯，收到在函数式编程会议上演讲的邀请非常有趣。我长期以来一直倾向于函数式风格。这促使我深入挖掘函数式编程的根源及其与 APL 的联系，
which is my first and remains probably my favorite array language. I mean, I think you're kind of given away by wearing the APL hat that you have donned on your head for the whole entire conference. So probably not a secret for most. I just can't get past the beautiful symbols. It's true. I mean, we'll put a link in the show notes, folks. I think people can purchase this hat if they want to, correct? It will be.
这是我的第一个，也可能仍然是我最喜欢的数组语言。我的意思是，我觉得你戴着整个会议期间一直戴着的 APL 帽子已经暴露了。所以对大多数人来说可能不是秘密。我就是无法抗拒那些美丽的符号。这是真的。我的意思是，我们会在节目说明中放一个链接，伙计们。我想如果人们想要的话可以买这顶帽子，对吧？会有的。
It will be so. It's not. Yeah. At the time of recording, it's not so, but it surely will be. This is a custom made hat that I thought that you could get these somewhere, but I guess I was mistaken. I've seen this expression online before. I'm not sure if it's the errands website where I've seen it. I've seen it from somewhere. Yes. Yeah, I adapted it from a functional composition of errands, and I needed to put on the English translation underneath.
会有的。现在不是。是的。在录制时还不是，但肯定会是的。这是一顶定制的帽子，我以为你可以在某个地方买到这些，但我猜我错了。我以前在网上见过这种表达。我不确定是不是在 Errand 的网站上看到的。我从某个地方见过。是的。是的，我从 Errand 的函数组合中改编了它，我需要在下面加上英文翻译。
Yeah, and I had actually, you showed in your talk, we're skipping the punchline here because you were about to tell us about your talk. But in the midst of it, I've seen the original tacit expression, but then you showed AA, which was above average, the one that you're showing here. And then you said the one below was NM, which is not mean, which you said you had a friend that refers to this as the don't be mean. Yeah, don't be mean. I had never heard that before. So this is the above average hat, and the next one is going to have the variant foot composition
是的，实际上，你在演讲中展示了，我们跳过了重点，因为你正要告诉我们你的演讲。但在过程中，我见过原始的隐式表达，但后来你展示了 AA，即“高于平均水平”，你在这里展示的那个。然后你说下面那个是 NM，即“不卑鄙”（not mean），你说你有一个朋友把这称为“别卑鄙”（don't be mean）。是的，别卑鄙。我以前从未听说过。所以这是“高于平均水平”的帽子，下一个将会有变体脚组合
and don't be mean underneath it. This is great. How long has this been a thing? Is this a recent development of tacit expressions, or has this been around for two decades and I just haven't stumbled across it? Well, I give worlds to know. I was talking to Adam, whom we Well, I give worlds to know.
下面写着“别卑鄙”。这太棒了。这东西存在多久了？这是隐式表达的近期发展，还是已经存在二十年了，而我只是没碰到过？嗯，我非常想知道。我正在和 Adam 谈话，我们……嗯，我非常想知道。
I was talking to Adam, whom we have on the Arraycast podcast, and saying we should get some merch. And he said, oh, it's on the APL wiki. There's a page for APL merchandise. Oh, really? And there's a page on the APL wiki with links to APL merchandise. But I couldn't find quite exactly what I wanted. But I followed to the platforms that provide this stuff and a little design work and made exactly what I wanted.
我正在和我们在 Arraycast 播客上的 Adam 谈话，说我们应该买些周边。他说，哦，它在 APL 维基上。有一个 APL 周边页面。哦，真的吗？APL 维基上有一个页面，上面有 APL 周边的链接。但我找不到我想要的。但我关注了提供这些东西的平台，做了一些设计工作，做出了我想要的。
So this is it. The name of the hat, folks, is the Above Average Hat. And it says above average in English, but above that has the APL tacit expression for above average. It's beautiful. Yeah, it flags all the items in a list where the values are above the average of the list. It's amazing, folks. It's all seven characters, right?
所以就是这样。这顶帽子的名字，伙计们，是“高于平均水平帽”。上面用英文写着“高于平均水平”，但在那上面有 APL 的隐式表达，表示高于平均水平。它很美。是的，它标记了列表中所有值高于列表平均值的项目。这太神奇了，伙计们。总共七个字符，对吧？
Yeah, I mean, yeah, one, two, three, four, five, six. You can't get better than that. Anyways, we totally got off track. Tell us about your talk. You're giving this a talk on array languages. I believe the title was Hooray for Arrays, a very nice poetic title, which is definitely your style. And you're giving this an origins and the inspiration of functional programming. And I knew vaguely that there was an association with Ken Iverson and APL, but I hadn't realized quite how closely bound together they were. Functional programming was introduced or first canvassed by John Backus in his 1977 Turing Award lecture,
是的，我的意思是，是的，一、二、三、四、五、六。没有比这更好的了。无论如何，我们完全偏离了轨道。告诉我们你的演讲。你正在做一个关于数组语言的演讲。我想标题是《为数组欢呼》（Hooray for Arrays），一个非常好的诗意标题，这绝对是你的风格。你正在讲述函数式编程的起源和灵感。我模糊地知道 Ken Iverson 和 APL 之间有联系，但我没有意识到它们结合得如此紧密。函数式编程是由 John Backus 在他 1977 年的图灵奖演讲中介绍或首次提出的，
is it possible to get away from the von Neumann style of programming? And apparently he had recommended Ken Iverson for the Turing Award, basically the Nobel Prize for software, and Iverson got it the following year. And in the Wikipedia article on functional programming, you can see that APL is credited as the inspiration for functional programming. So in my talk, I laid out some of the history about where Ken came from on the Canadian prairies of Norwegian stock. Very taciturn people. I thought you didn't make a joke about the fact that taciturn, you were saying the word and the prefix of that, that is tacit.
有可能摆脱冯·诺依曼式的编程吗？显然他推荐了 Ken Iverson 获得图灵奖，基本上是软件界的诺贝尔奖，Iverson 在第二年获得了该奖。在维基百科关于函数式编程的文章中，你可以看到 APL 被认为是函数式编程的灵感来源。所以在我的演讲中，我列出了一些关于 Ken 来自哪里，在加拿大草原上的挪威血统的历史。非常沉默寡言的人。我以为你没有开玩笑说“沉默寡言”（taciturn）这个词，你说这个词以及它的前缀，那是“隐式”（tacit）。
I thought there was a joke coming in there, but maybe it was just a tacit joke. Well, it's not so much a joke as a point. I mean, Ken wrote his textbook in a very taciturn style. And I was quoting Lee Childs a little later on in the talk saying what he liked about budget motels. Everything I need, nothing I don't. Yeah, yeah.
我以为那里会有一个笑话，但也许那只是一个隐式的笑话。嗯，与其说是笑话，不如说是一个观点。我的意思是，Ken 以一种非常沉默寡言的风格写了他的教科书。我在演讲稍后引用了 Lee Childs 的话，说他喜欢廉价汽车旅馆的原因。我需要的一切，我不需要的都没有。是的，是的。
There is... So we've got a forward focus that is trying to make a right-hand turn around an acute angle of a street. We literally have Rob Verding, around an acute angle of a street, we literally have Rob Verding, co-creator of Erlang, taking a video,
有……所以我们有一辆福特福克斯正试图绕过街道的一个锐角进行右转。我们实际上有 Rob Verding，Erlang 的共同创造者，正在拍摄视频，
or maybe it's a photo, of this Ford Focus attempting to make this turn. It's an impossible turn. They've done it. The Ford Focus is through. Anyways, back to you. Well, you know from our time together on the Arraycast that a recurring annoying theme of mine is the role of aesthetics in programming. And because we're all technical and we're all serious people,
或者可能是一张照片，这辆福特福克斯试图完成这个转弯。这是一个不可能的转弯。他们做到了。福特福克斯通过了。无论如何，回到你身上。嗯，你知道我们在一起参加 Arraycast 的时间里，我一个反复出现的烦人主题是美学在编程中的作用。因为我们都是技术人员，我们都是严肃的人，
we mostly don't like to talk about this or discuss it. But as best I can see, many of us are haunted by and in pursuit of the beautiful, except we pronounce it cool. I'm not sure if it was you I was talking to. I was talking to someone earlier today that was saying the folks that have gotten into array languages, I think it was you, were saying that one of the number one reasons they quote is why they got into it is because of the aesthetics of it. Yeah.
我们大多不喜欢谈论或讨论这个。但据我所见，我们许多人都被美所困扰并追求美，只是我们把它称为“酷”。我不确定是不是我在和你谈话。我今天早些时候和某人谈话，他说那些进入数组语言的人，我想是你，说他们引用的进入这个领域的第一大原因是它的美学。是的。
Something like that. This was at the Dialogue 24 conference in Glasgow two weeks ago. I was chairing a panel in which we were interviewing, kind of like a TV chat show, some young APLers, people recently into it. Now, back in the day when APL was a big thing, most of the people who came to it had done no programming before and it was easy to teach them this because they didn't know any different. But
类似的东西。这是两周前在格拉斯哥举行的 Dialogue 24 会议上。我主持了一个小组讨论，我们正在采访，有点像电视聊天节目，一些年轻的 APL 程序员，最近才进入这个领域的人。现在，在 APL 盛行的年代，大多数人之前都没有做过编程，教他们这个很容易，因为他们不知道有什么不同。但是
nowadays, most people who come to the array languages, it's not the first language, it's often not the third or even their fifth. And so there's a fair amount of unlearning to do to get competent with it. For many of them, APL would appear as, well, this is just basically very weird compared to all the other stuff I know. So one of the questions we asked was, how did you feel when you encountered this stuff what were you thinking and the second question was and why did you stick with it and that was the question the answers
如今，大多数进入数组语言的人，这不是第一语言，通常也不是第三甚至第五语言。所以要达到精通程度，需要进行相当多的“去学习”。对他们中的许多人来说，APL 看起来就像，嗯，这与我所知道的其他所有东西相比非常奇怪。所以我们问的问题之一是，当你遇到这些东西时你感觉如何，你在想什么？第二个问题是，为什么你坚持了下来？而那个问题的答案
were surprising me it's people were talking about the the beauty of it it's like i love coding this way i like right i don't which is what i felt half a century ago when i discovered it's like didn't really want to write code any other way. Yeah, you were in the Butcher Bird Combinator talk yesterday. Oh, you missed that. But there was a closure expression that they showed using, I think, three or four lines of code. And I saw it, and I thought to myself, that's three characters in APL and BQN. And sure enough, I worked that into my talk today.
让我感到惊讶，人们谈论的是它的美。就像我喜欢这样编码，我喜欢……这和我半个世纪前发现它时的感觉一样，就像真的不想用任何其他方式写代码。是的，你昨天参加了“屠夫鸟组合子”的演讲。哦，你错过了。但有一个 Clojure 表达式，他们展示了使用，我想是三四行代码。我看到了，我心想，那在 APL 和 BQN 中是三个字符。果然，我把它放进了我今天的演讲中。
And then one of the questions I got was, why are you such a fan of tacit? You seem like head over heels in love with this style. And I'm like, did you see the code at the beginning of the talk? The closure code, they literally had to build up an explicit lambda just to duplicate an argument that they could pass to a binary function. We have a symbol in all the array languages, APL, BQN, for duplicating an argument that's just a higher order function that you pass a binary function. Like, we have a symbol in all the array languages, APL, BQN, for duplicating an argument
然后我收到的问题之一是，为什么你这么喜欢隐式风格？你看起来对这种风格爱得神魂颠倒。我说，你看到演讲开始时的代码了吗？Clojure 代码，他们实际上必须建立一个显式的 lambda，只是为了复制一个参数，以便将其传递给二元函数。我们在所有的数组语言中都有一个符号，APL，BQN，用于复制一个参数，那只是一个高阶函数，你传递一个二元函数。就像，我们在所有的数组语言中都有一个符号，APL，BQN，用于复制一个参数
that's just a higher order function that you pass a binary. And it's just like, once you have that power, and it's elegant, it's beautiful when you write it that way, and then you don't, it's just like, why would anyone want to program any other way? I'm not sure if you have the same.
那只是一个高阶函数，你传递一个二元函数。就像，一旦你有了那种力量，而且当你那样写时它既优雅又美妙，然后你就不……这就像，为什么还会有人想用其他方式编程呢？我不确定你是否有同样的感觉。
For two years, for two years, Connor, I have been kidding myself that i'm learning python i keep putting it aside because i get bored and irritated i don't have a need to learn it i just feel i should probably know how to write python it's like oh really yeah it's i mean i do a lot of work in python you can be productive in it because they have so many libraries but there's a lot of work in Python. You can be productive in it because they have so many libraries, but there's a sense of not emptiness, but just like the, there's no elegance or beauty. Not to say that Python's on, I feel bad saying it's not a beautiful language, but it's just, you don't, it's not the same thing as programming in array languages. So back to Lambda World 2024, is this a conference you'd recommend to folks? I mean, is it, I think this is your first time
两年来，两年来，Connor，我一直在自欺欺人说我在学习 Python，我一直把它放在一边，因为我感到无聊和恼火。我不需要学习它，我只是觉得我可能应该知道如何编写 Python。哦，真的吗？是的，我的意思是，我在 Python 中做了很多工作，你可以在其中提高效率，因为他们有很多库，但在 Python 中有很多工作。你可以在其中提高效率，因为他们有很多库，但有一种不是空虚的感觉，而只是，没有优雅或美感。并不是说 Python 不……我为说它不是一种美丽的语言而感到难过，但它只是，你不会……它和用数组语言编程不是一回事。所以回到 Lambda World 2024，这是一个你会推荐给人们的会议吗？我的意思是，它是……我想这是你第一次
you said you were invited. So how did you find the overall conference experience compared to you were just at Dialogue24, which is purely like an array language conference? I probably shouldn't say this, but the conference chair throws a hell of a party. Well, we are right now outside a music bar, which is so, I wouldn't say rowdy, but it's just very loud and a lot of people inside that we have to come outside in order to have this conversation. So a dialogue doesn't do anything. They don't do music bars or anything like that. Dialogue was fun, but hasn't this whole thing been just a great party? Oh, no.
你说你被邀请了。所以与你刚参加的 Dialogue 24 相比，你觉得整体会议体验如何，那纯粹是一个数组语言会议？我可能不应该这么说，但会议主席举办了一个很棒的派对。嗯，我们现在就在一个音乐酒吧外面，这，我不会说吵闹，但里面非常吵，人很多，我们必须出来才能进行这次谈话。所以 Dialogue 没有做任何事情。他们不做音乐酒吧之类的东西。Dialogue 很有趣，但整个事情不是一个很棒的派对吗？哦，不。
Yeah. I can't recommend. I think all functional conferences in general are like, they're the array language cousins or siblings or something. Like, you know, when you go to an array language conference, it's your people. But the functional folks, they're just as curious as the array language folks. And so as opposed to going to conferences that are sort of more mainstream languages like Python, C++, Java, et cetera, those conferences are amazing in their own way. But it's more that like you're opening people's eyes at those conferences, whereas here, people are super curious and ready to pick up anything.
是的。我无法推荐。我认为所有的函数式会议通常都像，它们是数组语言的表亲或兄弟姐妹什么的。就像，你知道，当你去参加一个数组语言会议时，那是你的人。但函数式的人，他们和数组语言的人一样好奇。所以与参加那些更主流语言（如 Python、C++、Java 等）的会议相比，那些会议以自己的方式很棒。但更多的是，你在那些会议上开阔了人们的眼界，而在这里，人们超级好奇，准备好学习任何东西。
And also, too, being set in Cadiz, which I think the locals pronounce as Cadiz. I'm not sure if you can do it better. Cadiz. Cadiz. So, yeah, it's this peninsula on the coast of Spain that seems to be like a vacation destination place, which is surrounded by ocean on all sides. It's been absolutely gorgeous weather the entire time we've been here. Yeah. So I mean, what more could you want from the location of a
而且，设在加的斯，我想当地人发音为 Cadiz。我不确定你能不能做得更好。Cadiz。Cadiz。所以，是的，这是西班牙海岸上的一个半岛，看起来像是一个度假目的地，四面环海。我们在这里的整个时间里，天气一直非常棒。是的。所以我的意思是，你还能从一个
conference? Should we do a rake? Well, that was the other, that's the final topic we need to talk about. We were chatting about before we started recording here about the prospects of an ArrayCon. We've alluded to it on the ArrayCast at times. Is this something we should just go ahead and do? What's the status of ArrayCon 2020X? I've only just thought of this, so you're hearing it here first. We should do it back to back with LambdaWorld. Why have I actually never had this thought?
会议地点要求什么呢？我们应该做一个 ArrayCon 吗？嗯，那是另一个，那是我们需要谈论的最后一个话题。我们在开始录制之前聊过关于 ArrayCon 的前景。我们在 ArrayCast 上有时会提到它。这是我们应该直接去做的事情吗？ArrayCon 202X 的状态如何？我刚想到这一点，所以你是第一个听到的。我们应该把它和 Lambda World 背靠背举行。为什么我从来没有过这个想法？
I wonder if I'll keep this silence in because that's actually a fantastic suggestion. I don't know why I've never thought of something like this but that is exactly what a bunch of other conferences do. So I think I'm not sure if RacketCon now is a full-blown conference,
我想知道我是否会保持这种沉默，因为这实际上是一个绝妙的建议。我不知道为什么我从来没有想过这样的事情，但这正是其他许多会议所做的。所以我认为我不确定 RacketCon 现在是否是一个成熟的会议，
but there is a bunch of smaller community conferences that will co-locate with other conferences. I know that Strangeloop, while they had their conference up and running, it's shut down now. Rest in peace, Strangeloop. Never got to go. But they would always have these one-day or two-day conferences that would prefix for folks. That is a brilliant idea. Lambda World, is that what we're going to try and do next year? Sure. And they've got a great organization.
但有一堆较小的社区会议会与其他会议同地举行。我知道 Strangeloop，当他们举办会议时，现在已经关闭了。安息吧，Strangeloop。从来没去过。但他们总是会有这些一两天或两天的会议作为前缀。这是一个绝妙的主意。Lambda World，这就是我们明年要尝试做的吗？当然。而且他们有一个很棒的组织。
They've really put on a great party here. Like you're saying, smart, curious people. If we could hit your star, we could do a great ArrayCon right next to it. That's actually a really fantastic idea. We were already talking. Should we start an ArrayCon, or should we just slowly try and start to take over Lambda World? Because you gave a talk on arrays.
他们在这里举办了一个很棒的派对。就像你说的，聪明、好奇的人。如果我们能达到你的水平，我们可以在它旁边举办一个很棒的 ArrayCon。这实际上是一个非常棒的主意。我们已经在谈论了。我们应该开始一个 ArrayCon，还是应该慢慢尝试接管 Lambda World？因为你做了一个关于数组的演讲。
I gave a talk on function composition, but the languages I focused on were array languages. Camilla Shevchek, she gave a talk, attendee of Iverson College back in August and also a former guest of ArrayLanguage is. Camilla Shevchek, she gave a talk, attendee of Iverson College back in August and also a former guest of ArrayCast. Anyway, so it was four people, and I think there was a fifth, correct? Who am I missing?
我做了一个关于函数组合的演讲，但我关注的语言是数组语言。Camilla Shevchek，她做了一个演讲，八月份 Iverson College 的参会者，也是 ArrayCast 的前嘉宾。Camilla Shevchek，她做了一个演讲，八月份 Iverson College 的参会者，也是 ArrayCast 的前嘉宾。总之，那是四个人，我想还有第五个，对吧？我漏掉了谁？
This was from Habla Computing talking about functional working KDB, I think. Yes, that was the one-and-a-half-hour workshop yesterday, right? Yeah, I think that's right. Yeah, that was from Habla Computing. So, yeah, if you include workshops, technically, I had a workshop as well that was on tacit programming in array languages. So, anyways, we had two workshops, four talks, and I think we actually had a bunch of folks from the Habla Computing company, and KX was a sponsor of this conference.
这是来自 Habla Computing 的，谈论函数式工作 KDB，我想。是的，那是昨天一个半小时的研讨会，对吧？是的，我想是对的。是的，那是来自 Habla Computing 的。所以，是的，如果你包括研讨会，技术上我也做了一个关于数组语言中隐式编程的研讨会。所以，无论如何，我们有两个研讨会，四个演讲，我想我们实际上有一群来自 Habla Computing 公司的人，而且 KX 是这个会议的赞助商。
So, if there was a conference that we were going to co-locate with, this might be the one. So we will have to talk to... I haven't seen Louis here, the organizer. I was hoping to interview him because it's always good to chat with the organizers. The next thing once you turn the microphone off is we'll go talk to him.
所以，如果我们要和一个会议同地举行，这可能是最好的一个。所以我们将不得不和……我没在这里看到 Louis，组织者。我本来希望能采访他，因为和组织者聊天总是好的。关掉麦克风后的下一件事就是我们去和他谈谈。
All right, let's do that. This is the best idea I've heard in weeks, folks. In weeks. Thank you so much, Stephen. When's the next time we're going to bump into each other in person? It might be a while. November, isn't it? We're doing the next Raycast.
好的，我们这样做吧。这是我几周来听到的最好的主意，伙计们。几周来。非常感谢你，Steven。我们下次什么时候会亲自见面？可能要一段时间。十一月，不是吗？我们要进行下一次 Raycast。
That's virtually, though. So physically in person, it could be until 2025 sometime. Who knows? Who knows? See you down the road. I mean, it's been a pleasure seeing you. We met for the first time in August, and then we saw each other again a month and a half later here.
不过那是虚拟的。所以在线下见面，可能要等到2025年的某个时候了。谁知道呢？谁知道呢？以后再见。我是说，很高兴见到你。我们第一次见面是在八月，然后一个半月后我们又在这里见面了。
So it's been a blast bumping into you. And we are going to go talk to someone about a raycon 2025 folks be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions thanks for. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
能偶遇你真是太棒了。我们要去和别人谈谈Raycon 2025了，各位，请务必查看播客应用中的节目说明，或访问adspthepodcast.com获取我们今天节目中提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的GitHub讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。